البرتغالي مورينيو يثير ازمه في ديربي
روما تشافي يرد على انشيلوتي بشان هدف
ريال مدريد الملغي تبولا في الملعب فطربه
الحكم واقعه مثيره للجدل في ايطاليا هذه
الاخبار وغيرها تتابعونها عبر قناه
العربيه رياضه اسعدوا بمتابعتكم
نبدا اخبارنا لهذا اليوم مع الاشتباك الذي
ضجت به مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بين جوزي
مورينيو مدرب روما وكلاوتيو
عقب انتهاء الديربي الايطالي وبحسب صحيفته
لكزه فقد انتقلت توتر من داخل المعشب
الاخضر الى غرف تغيير الملابس وعلى اتمه
المنشور فقد سمح مفوض الاتحاد الايطالي
لمورينيو التواجد داخل غرفه تغيير الملابس
بعد المباراه رغم معاقبته لمبارتين وكعاده
المدرب البرتغالي لا يمكن ان يمر الامر
بسلام اشتبك مورينيو لفظيا مع لوتيتو
موجها الحديثه لاتسيو قائلا الى ماذا تنظر
ليجيب الاخر انا رئيس لاتيو ولكن من انت
هذا منزلي ويجب ان لا تكون هنا الصحيفه
اشارت ايضا بان مدير روما مضطر للتدخل
والتفريق بين الجانبين وتسببت الاجواء
المتوتره في اشتباك اخر بين لوس البرتو
لاعبسيو مع مساعدين مورينيو
نتحول الى الكلاسيكو في اسبانيا حيث
تباينت الاراء حول صحه الغاء حكم الفيديو
المساعد لهدف سجله مهاجم ريال مدريد
لم يتوقف عند مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بل
امتدا لمدربي الفريقين الايطالي كارلو
انشيلوتي مدرب الريال اكد ان فريقه لم يفز
بسبب حاله تسلل مشكوك فيه رد عليه تشافي
مدرب برشلونه بانهم متفاجئ من التصريح وان
حاله التسلل واضحه وقد تم اثباتها بطريقه
علميه وعادله لا داعي الى تشكيك فيها واكد
المدرب الكاتلوني ان فريقه
في موقع مريح للفوز بلقب الدوري الاسباني
ونبقى مع اجواء الكلاسيكو ولكن هذه المره
مع مشجع برشلونه حضر المباراه برفقه
حبيبته هذا العاشق اختاره مدرجات
لتقديم خاتم الخطوبه لفتاه احلامه قبل
بدايه اللقاء وامام الجماهير التي وقفت
وصفت فرحا لخطبته احتفاليه المشجع
الاسباني كانت مزدوجه خاصه بعد فوز فريقه
برشلونه وتحليقه في صداره الليغا بفارق 12
نقطه عن اقرب ملاحقيه ريال مدريد
الختام مع اللاعب كريستيانو بونيرو الذي
تلقى بطاقه حمراء غريبه في مباراه بدوري
درجه الثالثه الايطاليه المثير في الامر
ان اللاعب كان يجري عمليه الاحماء بشكل
طبيعي استعدادا للمشاركه وقبل الدخول
بدقائق قليله الى الملعب قرر التبول فجاه
وهو امر لاحظه حكم الرايه وفضح الواقعه
واخبره حكم الساحه الذي قام وبلا اي تردد
باشهار البطاقه الحمراء وطرد اللعب
[موسيقى]